[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magacín informativo 100 dedicado
al continente africano
yo soy liliana valencia y aquí damos una
mirada en profundidad a los hechos de
actualidad de la semana en la cuna de la
humanidad
hay polémica entre la república
democrática del congo y bélgica por el
único resto mortal que quedó del líder
independentista patrice en mary lumumba
quien fue asesinado y quemado de nacido
por agentes belgas en 1961 ahora las
autoridades del país accedieron a
entregarle a sus descendientes un diente
de lumumba y residente en kinshasa
las cifras de migrantes africanos que
pasan por marruecos e intentan llegar a
europa ya sea por el mediterráneo o por
el desierto de sahara se ha incrementado
considerablemente durante este año 2020
pero ahora los migrantes están
recurriendo a rutas aún más peligrosas
como las islas canarias tenemos reporte
desde marrakech
y la pandemia de koi 19 ha puesto en
peligro el derecho a la educación de los
niños en libia un derecho que desde hace
años ya se veía amenazado por el
conflicto armado que se vive en el país
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días porque casi
después de 60 años del asesinato de
patrice lumumba el gran líder de la
independencia de la república
democrática del congo finalmente podrá
tener una tumba en su país la justicia
belga entregará a sus hijos el único
resto de su cuerpo quemado e nacido tras
ser asesinado todo lo que quedó fue un
diente cuyo destino ha causado
controversia durante los últimos 20 años
cuando comenzó a hacer campaña por la
memoria de patrice lumumba este
activista no tenía idea de que su lucha
algún día giraría en torno a un diente
un vestigio de la justicia belga
entregará pronto a los descendientes del
primer ministro congoleño patricio
lumumba fue presuntamente asesinado por
la policía de belga con el apoyo de la
cia y las autoridades congoleñas pocos
meses después de la independencia ya es
un paso importante devolver el cliente a
la familia y al pueblo congoleño ahora
la pregunta es cómo lo vamos a lograr
porque sigue siendo uno de los
asesinatos del siglo y encima todavía
hay un juicio en curso la historia de
este diente es tan oscura como larga
durante años el policía encargado de
desaparecer el cuerpo de lumumba guardó
el diente en su casa y llegó a exponerlo
varias veces en televisión imágenes de
las que este escrito el congoleño aún no
se recupera
aún así vi a este tipo decir frente a
todos en la televisión que cortó a
lumumba en pedacitos y lo puso en ácido
lo contó como usted puede dar cualquier
pequeña historia es el tráfico de
cadáveres en un país civilizado no fue
sino hasta 2000
y 6 que el diente fue incautado por los
tribunales en el contexto de una demanda
interpuesta en bélgica por los
descendientes de patrice lumumba
logramos calificar el caso de asesinato
del señor lumumba como un crimen de
guerra por lo tanto no puede estar
sujeto a limitaciones de tiempos esto
nos permite continuar las
investigaciones casi 60 años después
pero la investigación lleva abierta más
de 9 años eso es lo que irrita este
sociólogo
cuyo libro publicado en 1999 condujo el
establecimiento de una comisión de
investigación en el parlamento
soy muy pesimista sobre la investigación
porque el fiscal general dijo que hasta
el momento todavía no ha escrito una
carta al parlamento belga para solicitar
los informes de las audiencias a puerta
cerrada con personas involucradas en el
asesinato aún prueba que no hay voluntad
de ir hasta el final de valjevo mud es
una historia oscura que le recuerda a la
gente la dolorosa relación de bélgica
con su antigua colonia vamos ahora a
marruecos porque organizaciones de
derechos humanos denuncian la
desaparición de más de 200 migrantes que
intentaban llegar a europa y también el
aumento de personas que arriesgan su
vida ya sea en el mediterráneo o en el
sahara
desde la ciudad de marrakech en
marruecos nos informó nuestra
corresponsal sofía catalá
el colectivo caminando frontera se
reportó de la desaparición de 247
personas migrantes que intentaban llegar
a las islas canarias en embarcaciones
procedentes de marruecos mauritania y
senegal en este caso se conocen las
desapariciones porque este colectivo
monitorea las fronteras europeas aquí en
marruecos y obtuvo información de los
familiares y pudo alertar pero en muchas
otras ocasiones estas desapariciones
simplemente no constan y ante el
incremento de la vigilancia en el
mediterráneo' las personas migrantes han
asumido rutas más peligrosas como es el
caso de la canaria ahora mismo el flujo
migratorio hacia las islas españolas es
cinco veces mayor al año pasado según la
oim m una de cada 20 personas muere y
caminando frontera se reportó 245
víctimas sólo en el primer trimestre del
año por otra parte la asociación
marroquí de derechos humanos y otras
organizaciones sobre el terreno alertan
del incremento de identificaciones
detenciones y deportaciones desde el
sáhara de donde sale en gran parte de
las embarcaciones y denuncian que las
inyecciones económicas de la unión
europea para que marruecos frene estas
salidas implican vulnerar el derecho a
la libre circulación de las personas
vamos ahora a libia donde las escuelas
que no habían cerrado a causa del
conflicto lo hicieron ahora por la
pandemia de ccoo y 19 la guerra ya
representaba un peligro para la
educación de los niños pero ahora el
virus termino de golpear las
posibilidades de escolarización
sus jóvenes vidas ya estaban
trastornadas por la guerra y la pandemia
sólo empeoró la situación
los alumnos sirios se enfrentan a nuevos
obstáculos para acceder a la educación
desde los primeros casos de kobe 19 en
el país las escuelas han intentado
diferentes tácticas desde dar clases en
exteriores hasta buscar donaciones de
desinfectante y mascarillas pero para
muchos es la primera vez que regresan a
la escuela desde hace seis meses
hola qué qué harán los estudiantes si
hay una nueva ola de coronavirus
perderán dos años de su educación este
es un gran problema para los padres y
los estudiantes vamos a tener una
generación de estudiantes con un nivel
de educación muy débil y sin embargo
incluso aquellos que no han recibido
cursos durante toda la pandemia tendrán
que presentar un examen para poder pasar
al siguiente grado según han dicho las
autoridades de mi hijo de cuarto grado
no estudio nada este año ni siquiera
aprendió el alfabeto lo que significa
que no sabemos qué pasará el próximo año
para el las decisiones del ministerio de
educación son aleatoria
y no se estudian bien
libia tiene ahora más de 40 mil casos de
coronavirus aunque con el caos
relacionado con la guerra en gran parte
del país los funcionarios admiten que
probablemente haya muchos más sin
detectar mientras tanto según
estimaciones de la onu los combates en
libia ya han desplazado a más de 150.000
personas 90.000 de las cuales son niños
también se han cerrado doscientas
escuelas privando a más de 200.000 niños
de su escolarización y también gran
parte de las escuelas en kenia siguen
cerradas los estudiantes requieren
ocupar su tiempo libre
una abuela deportista ocupa esos
espacios en impartir lecciones de
levantamiento de pesas a su familia ella
es una experta en esta materia incluso
representó a su país en campeonatos
olímpicos
a los 42 años mercy oviedo es una abuela
joven ella transmite su pasión por el
levantamiento de pesas a su nieta y a su
propia hija que también practican el
deporte ella fue la primera levantadora
de pesas de kenia en competir en los
juegos olímpicos y la segunda en el
continente
duca empecé a entrenar a mi hija menor
chanel ella está muy interesada siempre
viene conmigo a entrenar ya todas las
competiciones no ha sido de muchas de
ellas como mi asistente me motiva me
dice mamá hoy deberías estrenar levantar
200 kilos así que cuando ella está ahí
siempre hago las mejores actuaciones
mercy estuvo en los juegos olímpicos de
londres en 2012 en ese momento su hija
era muy pequeña pero recuerda este
evento
y cuando participó en las olimpiadas yo
estaba muy feliz la vi en la televisión
y estaba muy feliz y me dije que un día
yo también iría a los juegos olímpicos
comerci ha sido levantadora de pesas
durante 20 años tuvo que luchar contra
los comentarios misóginos de los hombres
que sentían que no era un deporte para
mujeres pero ella perseveró y ganó
varias medallas las escuelas en kenia
están cerradas debido al coronavirus por
lo tanto las niñas a menudo piden ir al
gimnasio para seguir los pasos de su
abuela dinámica
y hablamos también de somalia porque en
ese país las mujeres que juegan
baloncesto enfrentan la discriminación
de sus familias e incluso amenazas de
violencia por parte de una sociedad que
considera que el deporte es para los
hombres pero no para las mujeres esta es
la historia de un valiente equipo de
jugadoras en la capital mogadiscio
en somalia no es fácil jugar al
baloncesto siendo mujer muchos
islamistas creen que las mujeres no
deberían practicar deportes y la capital
mogadiscio es frecuentemente golpeada
por ataques llevados a cabo por
militantes de al shabab en hamar no es
que reservaron saint-marc mogadicio es
peligroso no podemos decir abiertamente
que vamos a jugar ponemos nuestro
uniforme y zapatos en mochilas escolares
y los llevamos en el campo y pretendemos
que vamos a la escuela oa la universidad
a pesar de la inseguridad y sin el
gobierno apoyándonos otan todavía nos
encanta jugar al baloncesto y armas
senior en doble nuevo incluso por
razones de seguridad las niñas y mujeres
juegan en recintos detrás de altos muros
de hormigón algunos de los entrenadores
comenzaron a entrenar aquí cuando
estalló una guerra civil en 1991 ventaja
neto cuando comenzó la guerra civil
muchos niños y niñas empezaron a
consumir drogas y pegamento
decidimos mantenerlos ocupados
organizamos los juegos de valència de
cinturón oval
me encantan estas chicas algunas más
tarde se unieron a la dirección nacional
y otras se fueron
a las mujeres aquí no reciben
financiación
los entrenadores no cobran pero les
apasiona el baloncesto y quieren formar
equipos en toda somalia
y para finalizar tenemos para ustedes
música que nos llega desde la república
democrática del congo donde la cantante
estará callum está lanzando su nueva
producción titulada post a kobe misa
donde rinde homenaje a los grandes de la
música tradicional de su país con esta
buena música finalizamos este capítulo
de áfrica siete días pero los invitamos
a continuar con más en nuestra página
web france24 puntocom nos dejamos con
esta música nos vemos más adelante
[Música]
la cosa rosa posa con machistas no
presión cosas como sapos
como semana más
[Música]
buenos días a todos yo me llamo usará
calumnia soy actriz y cantante
originaria de gran katanga en la
república democrática del congo tengo el
placer de presentarles hoy mi nueva
canción cosaco bin isa que salió este 16
de octubre de 2020 pues ha utilizado
cosaco bin isa es un homenaje a mis
padres papá buen baile françois lo ambos
makiadi y papá luz tumbas y mario
entonces yo he escuchado su música desde
mi infancia y me ha inspirado mucho el
mundo
la música congoleña es una herencia para
nosotros como congoleños pero también
para el continente africano en general
me gustaría que todos escucharan mi
canción posa que hoy niza porque tiene
un mensaje muy fuerte que ustedes de
verdad van amargos en grande con lo
visual es una pesada moto
[Música]
y todos esos artistas nos han mostrado
su arte y yo estoy muy agradecida con
ellos porque nos enseñaron esa bella
música que es la música congoleñas es un
homenaje ships pero no es únicamente eso
lo que quiero como artista yo quiero
darle luz a todas las jovencitas
talentosas que trabajan hombro a hombro
y que también quieren dar a conocer su
arte
o saco y misa ya está disponible en
todas las plataformas especialmente mi
cuenta de youtube será calume también me
pueden encontrar en las redes sociales
instagram facebook twitter snap trata y
mi página web y share calume queens y le
envía un saludo a áfrica siete días de
france 24
los adoro salto
[Música]
vamos a votar
una comisión
en tomate camino va a pasar yo puedo
castres yo con mis ojos
no matamos a todos así como quiénes
[Música]